Right, so, I was clicking around. I clicked here. It
seems like I can access a bunch of my objects.
>> Yup.
>>
clicked here, and this was interesting. So, what's going on with these guys?
>> Yeah, so, remember earlier when we overrode the global action layout
to be able to put in our create a set time action?
>> Yeah.
>> This is the global layout that you'll see from anywhere
inside this mobile app, if you haven't overrode the global layout.
>> Okay.
>> So you can create a Chatter post, create a new contact, maybe create
a task. All of these things are
actions that are quickly available to mobile users
to do from anywhere in the app.
>> Okay. So presumably that means. The the
action I made, the make a new set time.
>> Yep.
>> I can do that from my phone.
>> Yeah. Super easy.
>> So how would I do that?
>> Okay, so close the global actions. And if you scroll down. You can
see that we can click straight into
that Udacity Stage record. Like we saw earlier.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But instead of going that direction. Let's just use the
mobile navigation by clicking that little icon in the corner, yep.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And then scroll up.
>> Oh.
>> To the Show More. Click that guy, and just go to
the Stage tab, and we'll go straight to the record this way.
>> Okay, the Udacity Stage?
>> Yep.
>> Now, plus has at a set time.
>> Yeah.
>> It's pretty cool. Okay, so if I hit add a set time,
as I expect, has all these fields. So say it's just December 1st.
>> Sounds good.
>> status is new. Oh, cool, it has the automatic thing.
>> Yep.
>> Nice.
Time. I really like how it automates the pick list.
>> It just knows.
>>
>> Set the Udacity stage, and let's pick a band.
>> Yeah, let's go with U3 in.
>> Alright, so what we're looking at right now is the Udacity stage, you
know mobile page layout. It shows us all the fields that we saw in the computer.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Right?
>> But,
we can scroll left and right. And see different things on
this. So in this case, on this first window we can see
the Chatter feed. And so this is the set time we just
created, and here's the set time we created in the app earlier.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Now if we scroll to the right, we can see
the related lists of all the things related to this Udacity Stage.
>> Uh-huh.
>> So like the set times we just created.
>> Makes sense. Cool.